نذهب الى القاهره مخرج مسلسل نزوى امير
رمسيس يسعد صباحك امير معانا في صباح
العربيه انت كنت كثير مشغول بالفتره
الاخيره في مهرجان القاهره السينمائي
الدولي في ذات الوقت تصدر نزوى الاعلى
مشاهده في مصر والدول العربيه ما الذي
حمسك بالبدايه للخوض في هذه التجربه
الحقيقه
المنتجه الي فكره تحويل المسلسل الاصلي
الى النسخه المصريه هو مسلسل جدلي جدا
خطوط العلاقات في قد تكون حتى اكثر اثاره
الجدل في العالم العربي واعتقد كان تحدي
كبير طايح العمل على الجمهور العربي وقضى
على خلق التعاطف مع الشخصيات حتى مع
خروجهم عن المالوف الاجتماعي
طب امير كيف استطعتم التوثيق بين الجريمه
والاكشن وبين البعد الانساني في ذات الوقت
يمكن لان احنا حاولنا ان المسلسل يكون شبه
الحياه بشكل كبير يعني حاولنا ان حتى لو
مسلسل في لغز او في غموض ما بس شكل تنفيذه
ما يبقاش رايح ناحيه الجو البوليسي او جون
سيليو يعني ان هو يظل في شكل تصويره وفي
شكل التمثيل بتاعه الطبيعي ما بيحاولش ان
يسير همم ما يستخدمش اللاعيب الفيلم
البوليسي يعني او فيلم الجريمه بس يبقى اه
قبل فيلم اجتماعي تحدث فيه او مسلسل
اجتماعي في هذه الحاله بتحدث في جريمه قتل
بشكل طبيعي بدون ان تحول من نوع المسلسل
اطلاقا اعتقد ان الموضوع كان طبيعي جدا
بيني وبين خالد اولا علاقه علاقه ممتده
منذ سنوات نحن من مواليد نفس المدرسه
السينمائيه مدرسه يوسف شاهين لغه السينما
ولغه التمثيل مع بعض عائشه ممثله مختلفه
جدا
بتحاول تشتغل على نفسها بتحاول تشتغل على
الشخصيه اعتقد انك في اي هواجس بيننا بشكل
تناول العمل والشكل تناول الشخصيات يعني
طيب امير نحن كمشاهد دائما نحكم على
الممثل بانه كيف عاش وتقمص هذه الشخصيه
ولا ننسى ايضا بان للمخرج دور كبير جدا في
ان يعيش ايضا هو الحاله ويتقمص المسلسل
كله حدثنا ايضا عن هذه النقطه امير بحكم
انت مخرج المسلسل
الحياه دائما انا يعني مقتنع ان العلاقه
بين الممثل والمخرج تحديدا هي اكثر
العلاقات
صعوبه ولكن في صناعه السينما احنا في
الاخر بنتعامل معه عنصر سينمائي بيتفاعل
مع عناصر اخرى كلها هي جزء من رؤيه المخرج
انتقاضى على التحكم فيها بالكامل وعندك
عنصر اللي هو العنصر البشري اللي هو هيتحط
قدام الكاميرا مهما عملت برويبات عمره ما
ينفذ اللي عمله بالضبط
انا باكره كلمه قياده الممثل قياده المخرج
مع الممثل كيف تستطيع ان تخلق هذا التواصل
عشان تقدر ان هو حتى
الممثل نفسه بيدخل في جولدش جلد الشخصيه
ممكن الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
امام الكاميرا احساس معين يبقى خارج من
سياقتي نفس الشخصيه مش من الممثل يعني لو
خالد عمل ده فهو عمر شاهين اللي بيعمل ده
وليس خالد النبوي
ز مؤخرا على الاعمال القصيره يعني كنا
نعتاد على اعمال رمضانيه مثلا تمتد الى 30
يوم واكثر ويكون لها جزء اول وثاني وثالث
يمكن لان الدراما بتاعتنا او الدراما
المسلسلات ابتدت اقرب شويه من الشكل
الدولي الاولاني احنا لو شفنا المسلسل لو
شفنا اغلى من المسلسلات دي هي منفذه
بتقنيه سينما بحركه بحركه السينما الاضاءه
شكل التصوير الالوان اا شكل السيد حتى
فيمكن ال 30 حلقه القديمه الكلاسيكيه همم
هي شكل في شيء من المط والتطهير اي حبكه
دراميه بيجعل من المستحيل انك تصنعها همم
بهذا الايقاع السينمائي يمكن هو بحث عن
ايقاع اكثر اجازه للمتفائك دائما يتفرج
على المسلسل
بتبقى ست حلقات وسبع حلقات او ثمان حلقات
وتعود على الاضاءه ده فكان لازم يحصل همم
قفزه بشكل صعيدي في الدراما العربيه
اللي عمل يتصدر بالاساس الاخراج النص
التاليف اشخاص ممثلين بارزين
اعتقد انه يعني تكامل هذه العناصر مع بعض
بس قبل اي حاجه الفكره اعتقد الانجذاب
للفكره نفسها هو في 60% من حماس الجمهور
للعمله